that pocketing [ __ ] can he just open
doors normally
okay this time I'll just stay here and
wait them out
drink some I don't know what this could
be
carpets I love conference em I just want
to hug you
oh [ __ ] don't tell me you're part of the
ballot did you tell him
carpet to tell me the truth Carver tell
me
not even carpet seasons
they're good you can go now
alright I'll just go oh man right in the
face why did my beautiful face get Nina
we're sexy let's go no problem no
problem
blammo
I can't let these
cap take these either think I need to go
tell me to do anything
I see
let's go here downstairs yeah perfect
that's where I want to go
all right good good good perfect just a
splat all right whatever carpets I hate
you
just did it open Oh even this okay
whatever
they'll have to I don't need I need oil
thank you thank you thank you so problem
the problem yes go let's go what are you
[ __ ] kidding me how can it odd
carpets I knew it I use this humping
though just tinderbox is everywhere
don't need your tinderbox
that's point I don't understand is it
some deep meaning
okay we didn't go in the camera go let's
go go fire there I get the feeling I
have to run soon let's just take it soft
oh [ __ ] it's so bad he's so bad pick up
the lighting that amount amount and the
tinderboxes and I gave me good this is a
laboratory I must be off [ __ ] [ __ ]
of course
not again yes not again mentioning
anything no mother don't something is
everywhere I find a key it's probably
upstairs
god damn Barbara Barbara we went in
there oh we did it
we only went all right sweetie it's not
even here
yes I get if you're really fat and
obnoxious and you want Stan more it's
cool I guess I've been there done that
actually no but whatever I have to break
this so much better
serious have to find the key though I
thought I would visit every room
barrels everywhere don't tell me I
missed the key
don't tell me and someone's gonna leave
in the comments oh you missed the key
it's right there 11:35 I don't see it
I don't see the key no I really don't I
swear
let's go upstairs I look very nice
where my keys at where my keys at where
my keys I sing with me
hey okay so
I guess we can take another room
let's go there is where we came from
here looks pretty neat actually probably
not but
thank you sir
alright this is Alex on this room even
as a portrait himself my love why have
you returned not return to me you said
you would not be long gone life but at
home was a year has passed how long must
I and all this loneliness sometimes I
think that you can you only left to get
away for me is that who I always try to
be a good wife I try to show you the
love I feel for you and now you're gone
as it's all of the why I can no longer
take down my sauce I am miserable
come back to me so this is his wife
office sorry
yes I'll take that Akira man
who want who doesn't want a piece of
that sexy-ass I understand mrs. mrs.
I understand
let's go in here bedroom if you know
what I mean another key I guess
absurd only the little king kelana cough
cough lalana meet you Barney
all right so hear that
master petrol
I'll just lay here and wait for the
penis
like sure I'll do that Smollett I like
the vessel example I cannot wait and
along was outside my Artemis every day
I don't think you are coming back
what's not sorry but it's way too long
and I already read so much that could be
a backseat boy song just saying yes
so that's library perfect
I would assume there's nothing in here
why do they have to make if things
realistic like a walking closet why did
they have to have that I don't think it
I'm not leaving at a father moving
thesis sweet sharp brush sweet right
I let that know I can
think we should go here just room [ __ ]
don't go there either
everything that's the key these days I
don't not again
there's locker room key key key key key
key key
they shared a lot of keys when they make
these mods Josh I'm knocking I think
this was library first McGrath been here
like two seconds ago
I'm a genius you're jealous Anderson
regarding the estrogen the guest room
has been still off due to uh well
accident its unhappy little and complete
disarray the door has been locked in the
keys now stored in self-love Larry
sherry alright let's go poof proof that
the other ones exists on your own
last night I was working in the lab I
was busy mahabhava okay if you wanna
read that go ahead I don't really tell
her to read so much you know my throat
hurts when I do these freakin voices too
much okay third floor first floor second
floor so this is the floor
let's go find the key it's probably just
too bad you are you happy
oh man I'm it's like door gee I mean
long after long it's just going here
that guy sure loves to have hang
pictures only in the self-same not that
good-looking
and I am standing wait awkwardly close
to his
nothing in here nothing really
this is wery two of them I'm your
nightmare let's go first floor then I
guess yay perfect
ouch no wait this is right is there a
door there nope
so that means that means that means no
no I can't crap
there's got to be something in here come
on give me something
oh wait I'm a genius I'm a genius
okay that was lucky but whatever
whatever duck you said I don't know whoa
whoa I noticed there was something going
on there
ah [ __ ] walk down the stairs no problem
I spoofer mother [ __ ] Cooper's okay
let's find the key and get that freakin
fridge out of here yeah I've got the key
no problem let's go okay okay I'm sorry
I'm sorry about everything
I didn't mean to touch your ass I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I should have
known like he doesn't even have a face
and he's settling in a library yeah that
makes sense getting kind of pissed off
at this model
look at me I'm dancing I'm dancing I
don't ma'am
this is least I'll uh huh oh geez so now
we have the key to the guest room and we
can go yay
I'm excited
so we've been everywhere right yeah so
here we will find the key to that oh
yeah we need
and then we're done see hopefully too
many oh this is pretty well lit up and
happily I'm happy I got
guest rooms are always nice I love guest
rooms I'm gonna answer on the table I
think what we need to do is
I why did I say I don't trust you
I don't either don't trick on me mr. mr.
science I mean it's all here foolish man
he doesn't realize I stole his key ha ha
ha I swallowed it then I [ __ ] it out I
mean I did I now he will never be able
to conduct any more horrible experiments
on the innocents I'm sure he will kill
me but at least I can die knowing I will
wha what
oh I was so what who put you back I
don't trust you
wait let it say something differently
I have to read that again I don't trust
you
he's so monkey now he's dead haven't
found the key despite the title surging
room I turned the whole place upside
down and still nothing I suppose I can
make another one alright with where's
where's it was he wasn't it maybe he
just wants his helmet this may be I
don't know
doesn't have a face maybe wants to cover
it up
oh [ __ ] why did I do that so I didn't
mean the door either I thought he was
you have a oh [ __ ] okay I think oh [ __ ]
I didn't mean to touch your shirt am I
done in here or what I want that I want
that that [ __ ] let's hug the wall
maybe shake the drawers again
I don't understand
yeah you really do hate me
I get the feeling at us right listen
here oh man he's he wants me but no I
don't want you oh I think I know what we
don't need to do we have to rape them it
makes sense right
no I think we need to cut out it's just
yes you dig through the corpse and pull
out the key where exactly did we pull it
out I don't see many holes except no no
Daniel you are a [ __ ] paranoid okay
you have the laboratory all right bye we
can go
[ __ ] I'm on fire today I'm solving
puzzles like a [ __ ]
three-sixty just for fun I'm a crazy guy
sometime
I think there was laboratory but it
doesn't really make something
yeah ask me what it feels like staring
at the sky so Vendela telling Kurt
Russell homie to say real life I'll be
making good on my promises honesty is
pop it inside of it is listen but I
realized I can't be better than I was
later on my feet cooking up the song
when we fire up